all right hey everybody welcome back 6
42 right now it is time for mondays with
monica we are eight months into this
pandemic i know you're exhausted
i feel your pain not only uh can it take
a physical toll on people especially
those who
get sick with covet but it also has been
mentally exhausting
for kids and adults but in particular
kids you've seen the reports
joining me now to talk about ways to
make sure that your kiddos
are mentally healthy is aisha grevenberg
she's a licensed clinical social worker
and psychotherapist
aisha thank you so much for being here
how you doing
i'm doing well good morning good to see
you hey and it's good to see you too my
friend you know in the teas i said she's
going to give
some great information but she's very
stern i love your matter-of-fact
approach so let's get right into it what
are some signs that parents should be
aware of
that signal that their kiddos are
struggling with mental health issues
the very very first thing is if there's
any change in their normal routine
if they're not coming out of their room
if they're not talking to the friends
that they usually
talk to if they're not talking to you
the change in routine
is key that's most important also
it's very very important that you pay
attention to their mood
so their mood is if they're feeling sad
if they're feeling
irritable if they're feeling anxious
that's key you have to pay attention to
that
most importantly this is so important
if they are showing any signs of
hopelessness
any signs that they feel like this is
ridiculous there's no point i'm tired of
this
that's the key that's when you need to
call me you need to call another
therapist that's when you need to ring
the alarm that's hopeless
it's the key that just gave me chills
when you said that
how can parents don't support their
kiddo's mental health given the
uncertainty
of the pandemic because they they're
asking questions i say this with every
parenting segment and it scares me to
death as a parent
and my kid is 14. those questions they
can throw you off your game
they really can and the hard part is
that we don't really have any answers
yeah no one has any answers but the
reality of it is is
we really didn't have any control ever
right yeah and so
giving kids the most accurate
information that's age appropriate
is the very best thing that we can do
it's so important that we
listen to them kids are not dumb they
know what's going on
and they're scared the same way we are
scared and so
validating how they feel asking them to
talk to you
that's the key it's so important that we
treat them like
people they are experiencing this the
same way we are so give them
information that's age appropriate okay
so what are some of the activities that
parents can do with their kiddos to
build
healthy supportive relationships so let
me tell you get kids to tell you about
these little dances that they're doing
have them teach you how to do the dances
have fun really make it as fun as you
can get out there and just get jamming
with these kids
let them show you the music they like
get engaged
be really curious about their friends
ask them who their friends are
don't be messy but be encouraged okay
ask them questions let them talk to you
be curious that's the most important
thing
plan a garden you see i got my plants
here yeah tell them every day
name them be engaged and do things
together it's not about spending a lot
of money
it's about spending time absolutely this
last question i'm going to tread lightly
but
you've been doing this for 18 years and
i know you're training educators in new
york as well
as here in las vegas so listen to me
carefully how do parents
address the issue of santa
whether or not he will show up for
the holiday for christmas this year
because of covet you picking up what i'm
putting down
i am i got it i got you yeah what i
would say is really for children that
are much
younger and let them know that santa's
thinking of them
and loves them and that we are going to
gonna santa's gonna do the very best
that he can to
visit every child every child and make
sure every child is healthy
and every child is safe that's what you
want to emphasize for this christmas for
this holiday
letting your children know that santa's
definitely coming but santa
is bringing health santa is bringing
some face masks
santa's bringing some sanitizer okay we
want to keep things safe and keep our
kids encouraged
we can't let them lose their hope that
was the perfect answer
if folks need to get a hold of you real
quick i should tell me
so the very best thing please call your
hr department you may have access to
free capital free therapy sessions
and then call your insurance but for me
you can find me or any other therapist
on psychology today
we are here we want to help you you are
not alone i promise you you're not alone
all right thank you my friend so good
seeing you i appreciate all of your
advice take care and happy holidays to
you